hertha erst mal wir haben es jetzt aus
der politik gehört haben gerade selber
auf den zahlen gesehen
sie verändern sich nicht stark also
heute zum ersten mal mit 10.000 da weiß
man noch nicht ganz genau ob das
wirklich die richtigen zahlen sind
ansonsten den letzten wochen leider kein
sinkflug zu sehen bei den zahlen ist
jetzt überhaupt der richtige moment um
über neue maßnahmen zu sprechen kann man
schon sehen wieder locker und sich
bisher auf die infektion entwickelt hat
ausgewirkt hat also ich kann nur sagen
für lockere sehe ich gar keinen
spielraum wir sind zwar etwas weniger
starken anstieg als wie vor einer woche
aber das heißt dass wir nach hilfe einer
hohen geschwindigkeit in der ansteckung
haben und da muss wirklich etwas
passieren und auch das was ihre tochter
von in berlin gesagt hat die schulen
dass wir das zentrale problem werden
weil wir müssen die schulen offen halten
das kann ich gut verstehen aber damit
dass smart das heißt schichten system
das heißt auch samstags unterricht auch
wenn der zugleich schmerzhaft ist aber
dafür werden ja auch zwei tage durch in
nrw mehr gegeben oder aber auch zum
beispiel schichtmodell eine woche
anwesen hat eine woche im brief über
computer fernunterricht und dass man
dann wechselt aber wir müssen da
wirklich aufpassen weil sonst haben
kriegen wir irgendwann davon wie am
meisten an österreichische verhältnisse
nämlich nicht nur die krankenhäuser
wegen alleine laufen langsam zu zum
beispiel hier bei uns ich heute morgen
um viertel vor sieben war meine erste
blutabnahme und der tag geht dann bis 20
uhr heute durchgeht
ich bin nicht der einzige und wir
könnten das lange nicht mehr durchhalten
auch nicht mehr meine mitarbeiterin und
die kollegen hier im umkreis
also das ist eine große strukturelles
problem und da müssen wir höllisch
aufpassen
sagen wir warum genau sinken die zahlen
jetzt nicht so wie auch oft liegt es
daran dass sich die menschen nicht genug
an den doktor anhalten oder dass die
maßnahme ist ganz einfach per se nicht
reichen
ich glaube es ist eine mischung von
beiden einmal das natürlich viele sagen
gerade auch die jüngeren hat das
betrifft mich nicht nur die alten werden
richtig krank und warum gehen und auch
wie gesagt
es ist gerade wenn man zur schule geht
dann vor dem schulhof oder wer das
während der busfahrt gibt es im normalen
christian das kann ich alles gut
verstehen aber das ist genau
kontraproduktiv weil dann natürlich der
virus weitergegeben wird
und da muss man sagen okay bitte leute
müssen sich vielleicht noch ein bisschen
strenger an den regeln halten und dann
muss man wirklich überlegen muss man
jetzt eingehen und noch eine
verschärfung machen in waadt zum
beispiel wie man sagt wirklich wie auch
geplant ist würden sich nur noch mit
einem haushalt trifft und ein oder
maximal zwei personen mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau dir
das nächste video an und vergiss nicht
zu abonnieren